[Music]
hello and welcome to Dear John and Hank
or as I like to think of it the actual
name of the podcast dear Hank and John
sorry I think I've been gone for a few
weeks and I wanted to just take control
of the reins today it's a comedy podcast
about death where two brothers offer you
dubious advice answer your questions and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and duck tada AFC Wimbledon lead
one's richest side more to come later in
the podcast news John how are you doing
today well we're in real life together
Hank we're in Los Angeles California
I'm in a great mood because the movie
rights to my book
turtles all the way down the the it's
happening someone purchased them not for
someone the same people or I'm at a fox
mm who made the Fault in Our Stars and
Paper Towns movies Elizabeth Gabor and
Erin siminoff how do you find out about
that what happens when you find out that
someone got the movie rights to your
books as a person who has no thing that
this will one day maybe happen to him no
thing have you been drinking a little
bit okay um so you get a first you get a
phone call that says that somebody's
interested in the movie rights and then
in this case like eight weeks later
after lots of conversations and talking
about how to visualize deeply internal
abstract thought processes you decide to
do it I'm excited I'm so it's just I did
not think that this would ever be a
movie I didn't think that anybody could
see it as a movie boy um I don't know I
was just so moved by the way they talked
about it and the way the way that
they're thinking about it and I can't I
can't wait I am really thrilled though
not everything that gets option becomes
a movie it's not guaranteed to become a
movie but it is really exciting and
these it's the same people who made the
Fault in Our Stars in Paper Towns movies
I trust them so much the relationship
that we we've had over the years has
been so cool so it's really exciting how
are you doing
I'm good it's late John 9:27 uh it's we
it's late for me I'm sleepy I got up at
4:40 this morning so there that's that's
how I'm feeling but I'm glad that we
could be in the same place to make a
podcast together and I'm glad that we
could learn together a little bit about
what people are curious about in the
world and also maybe about cups well you
haven't been drinking um Hank yeah would
you like a question from our listeners
you don't want to read my poem
what's your poem my poem and I posted
about the fruit flies you can just go
ahead and read it people can people get
here oh you're typing and it makes them
think that you're not paying attention
to the pod I'm sure not my fruit fly
Pola a fruit fly flew through my window
screen there between the window and the
screen she pew pated now too large to
fit back through the screen she wanders
in the sunlight searching alone it's
good Hank
I would not pursue a career as a poet as
such I think that was very good there's
also a huge problem which is the adult
fruit flies can't pupate we're just it's
not like that's not how it works
well I'm like larvae pupae and they
become adults and that's the whole thing
and I feel weird that that is
scientifically inaccurate and also bad
poem got 2,000 likes on Twitter 2,000
likes
and people really will hit that heart
button for anything these days well I'll
tell you what that actually one of my
more successful tweets recently um you
know I've noticed that there's this
whole thing on Twitter where people are
taking that great William Carlos
Williams poem about the plums and
turning it into lyrics from the popular
music song all-star are you familiar
with this meme no do you know do you
know the poem in question no but I do
know all-star okay great
so there's a wooden cart William poem I
don't know exactly how it goes but I'm
gonna give you my version of it this is
my attempt to recite a William Carlos
Williams poem I've had a couple drinks
but fewer than Hank I have taken the
plums that were in the
icebox and which you were probably
saving for breakfast
forgive me they were delicious so sweet
and so cold and here's the version
that's been making the rounds on the on
the on the social media Hank okay hey
now you're an icebox get your palms on
so sweet that's not the best version hey
I thought the best version at all uh I
was on a website that was telling me
these plum jokes and now there's a video
playing this construction unfolds into a
home in just hours and costs only thirty
three thousand dollars and I'm like this
is not what was happening I was not on a
home construction website I was looking
at whoa suddenly angry from like
Pleasant drunks a really aggressive
belligerent drunk what I just don't like
it with videos autoplay Jonas you are
you are coming way too hard about videos
autoplay by the way you know where I
like videos auto-playing at youtube.com
slash vlogbrothers because it's because
it's what I'm there for
how do you how do you like a moment on
Twitter now I'm falling asleep and she's
eating my plums and he's opened the
icebox and she's taking the plum now I'm
looking for plums and my stomach feels
sick now it's all in my head so sweet
and so cold now I don't really know how
that song goes I'm Shay then then Nick
for Hanks sake do wheat that a little
bit of cold plums in my lair you go a
little bit of icebox by my side a little
bit of breakfasts what you need a little
bit of forgiveness is what I seek a
little bit of delicious those those
plums little lovely plums alright here
we go here we go you got that one's got
15,000 likes well the plums start coming
and they won't stop coming got it hit
the icebox for some more cold woman did
it make sense to igloo didn't make sense
to eat lukewarm plums you got the icebox
so go chill them son I don't think this
person's ever actually heard all-star
but that was close
close that was like there's like an
algorithm wrote a version of all-star I
had a version of that William post which
I saw like like happening on Twitter
there were cold plums yeah and people
were talking about it that's as far as I
got into the meme until now and I feel
like I'm explaining something that
everybody already knows about but the
great thing is that because we're
recording this in the relatively distant
past everyone will have forgotten about
this meme by the time the video remember
the good old days
oh I'll be back with all those terrible
things that have happened since then
hadn't happened and we joked about Blum
least it wasn't a nuclear winter this
first question comes from Nick who
writes dear John and Hank I've been sick
lately my doctor told me to try gargling
with salt water to help my sore throat
while we're stirring up a mug of the
stuff using an art assignment mug I got
from dftba.com my number one source for
branded drink ware man this guy knows
how to get his question asked Fonzie
right on I started to notice that as
more and more of a salt began to
dissolve the sound of my spoon tapping
against the inside of the mug became
gradually higher and higher in pitch
until all the salt was dissolved and the
pitch became consistent I was able to
replicate this with another mug of salt
water later on I haven't measured the
difference but from what I could tell
the [ __ ] raised by nearly an octave
whoa
still sick comma Nick oh nice I am
impressed yeah that you can tell the
pitch change you are like oh that I did
it in the question to ask another
question asker great yeah good because
I'm a great singer oh all right bit of
Plum life in my life a little bit of
Plum life Ron's life what is it what's
the answer
so I have noticed this a number of times
when I'm stirring Gatorade yeah to a cop
because you got him you gotta stir that
Gator have you gotta buy a bottle of
Gator liquid Gatorade you yeah but I
know that you know you come from a
humbler background it's harder for
background yeah in the same home with
you
oh just more recently I I don't just buy
powdered Gatorade for frugality I also
get to make it the exact love
of sweetness that I want which is not
the sweetness I mean obviously it's
never gonna be the exact preference of a
person if it's standardized for
everybody so I like to be able to make
my gatorade to the sweetness that I want
and there's only one way to do that two
ways you could buy liquid Gatorade and
then water it down also we could do that
but I like to do it my way I like what I
actually like it a little bit sweeter
that it comes so what I do is I just
open the bottle up and I wait for eight
or nine days just for some evaporation
but everybody has a different way but
that's my vase at all times I like aging
your Gatorade
I always have ten open bottles of
Gatorade at different levels of
sweetness why does this happen
it was the question not how do you like
your Gatorade well the problem John is
but I don't really know but I wanted to
talk about Gator in a pet but it's weird
to me because the pitch lowers when I'm
using Gatorade and apparently goes up
when you use salt so probably have
something to do with viscosity then
that's all that's all I got for you
somebody knows the answer this question
in fact I've read an article about this
and I forgot it I forgot it
because that's what you do with
information this next question comes
from Andrew who writes dear john and
hank i discovered the podcast last week
and I don't listening to eight episodes
a day while at work Henry you work too
much
also you listen to podcasts too much
while you're working getting divorced
after 25 years of marriage
well this took this took a turn well I
know they'll be both happier after it
the whole thing is making me cynical
about love does all love fade over time
what's the point in trying if over half
of marriages fail how do I stop this
from happening in my future romances I
appreciate your dubious advice
definitely not a hurricane Andrew first
off Andrew not over half of marriages
fail mmm-hmm all marriages end either in
death or divorce annulment good point
Hank really good so all marriage is
failing good because nothing lasts
forever not even cold November rain as
guns and roses once memorably put it ah
good very all very good every rose has
its thorn just like every cowboy has a
sad sad song
just like every doesn't rhyme every box
yeah every poem every cold poems every
boyfriend eats that plum and the box
weight start over from scratch so it
seems like you're just coming up with it
now every plums cold a new box yeah that
right that's good and every boyfriend
steals your plums from that bah that's
good
what B gotta you gotta hit the last note
you got to be like every plum in that
box I don't either but by the way I
don't think that song is November rain I
think it is a different song from the
same era yeah it's definitely the case
yeah that's every rose has its thorn
every rose has its thorn hey by the way
Andrew I'm gonna answer your question is
that every rose has its thorn man I mean
that's that here's that's true no and
every in cold November rain even that
ends yeah it's also true that every
every rose has its thorn love is a rose
so you better not pick it it only grows
when it's on the vine
very true a handful of thorns didn't
know you missed it you lose your love
when you steal freakin ice box from
plums I don't think you steal the ice
box from the close as such that's the
second time we've made it as such joke
is I don't know if it is Nick cut off
the as such as he didn't need to you
didn't he didn't need to go there here's
the thing Eddie I'm sorry that your
parents getting divorced but it should
not make you cynical about love because
love brought you into this world love is
both how you became a person and also
why you became a person to quote my own
book turtles all the way down and don't
be it's okay to go through a mourning
process and a grieving process and I
think that's naturally I'm good but that
does not mean that life is hopeless it
just means that life does involve loss
yes and that things that are wonderful
don't last forever like roses maybe I
don't know also like plums in the icebox
I mean no matter how cold
icebox is nothing lasts forever
eventually they're not gonna they're
gonna be a little there
what are plums when they're tried
they're gonna be pruned that's why I had
to eat the plums I just you were saving
them for breakfast but I breakfast when
tomorrow why eat them tomorrow when you
can eat them today all right Hank this
next question I got asked um today's
it's John question day I missed three
weeks I've been this is good sure it go
this next question comes from a9c writes
Dear John and Hank last year I
participated in a stage production
theater workshop thing on the day we
were supposed to present our final
product to play our lovely stage
director decided to do a few exercises
to calm our nerves before the show it
only ended up making me more anxious
like everything that's ever been
designed to calm anyone haha anyway that
wasn't the question she instructed us to
scream out loud as loud as we could one
after the other only one problem I don't
know how to scream so while waiting on
my turn I was trying to understand the
mechanism that is screaming while
simultaneously asking the people next to
me how they acquired the art of
screaming which only made me more
confused because the kind of advice I
received went along the lines have I
don't know just let it flow but what
does that mean how do I let it flow what
do I need to let flow so many questions
I didn't end up finding out how to
scream and I proceeded to let out a
weird guttural noise that resembled a
loud snore I am sacred to almost any
advice on how to scream alright here's
what I want you to do a nice don't you
close your eyes I want you to imagine
that there's an ice box
saving these blob she's insane the flows
were so long they're just they've
reached the perfect moment between plum
and prune and like moment at which you
love to have them for breakfast they say
that every plum has its thorn but not
these plums in fact no plums I don't
think they say that do that every plum
has its thorn never heard that one
anyway a nice I want you to picture that
situation and then you open that icebox
and what is in there nothing now how do
you feel right now
ah hmm that wasn't it that wasn't a
scream we're not
bro it's true if we scream something and
I'm 42 yeah I don't wanted to get
security uh this is really interesting
to me because I think that la that's
awful
that's definitely not a scream the other
day I'm going to go down one often the
other day I had a baby carrier on yeah
and it has this like mechanism you have
to push multiple buttons at the same
time to unlock it so that like your baby
doesn't accidentally fall out or
something and I only hit one of the
right buttons and I pulled and then I
the gap was created and then my finger
went in the gap and then I couldn't get
it out my hand slipped and it slid onto
my finger yeah and it pinched me so hard
that it broke the skin and I made this
noise in the back of the car with the
baby and Katherine thinks the baby is
making that noise because it's a
terribly a varied knob that human man
noise yo and and she's like freaking out
like what's wrong well that's a very
weird really the baby make and it just
but then I pulled my hand out and I mean
it oh wow I think we could aleut that
noise that you just made and turn it
into a really bad Prince song like it
would be the worst Prince song there are
no bad Prince songs that's a good point
Hank
well I could loop the sound that you
just made and turn it into like a cover
a really bad cover of a really good
ransom this next question comes from war
did we answer that one oh yeah how do
you scream I just think this is
interesting I think that it's like
knowing that you don't know how to make
all the noises cuz it's like it took me
a while to realize that that right there
were noises I hadn't learned and I just
had to learn them like of course when I
was like a child and learning to speak
but you can speak in different ways and
getting gaining full use of your voice
or at least more use than you are than
you once had it's like a process and
it's not something that everybody just
does and I know a lot of people who have
a hard time making loud noises I still
can and I think just work I think it's
legitimately
you have to go someplace where you no
one is listening right like I'm gonna
try to make noises like other people do
or just don't learn how to scream yeah
and just wait for the moment when you
really need it and then I bet you'll
find it like when it's an emergency and
it's not like the stage manager being
like I don't have to get rid of your
anxiety let's have everybody scream by
themselves like if everybody's coming
together at least then I can fake it but
it's like you scream right no I don't
yell in front of a bunch of too much
pressure
yeah it's terrifying they're terrifying
but you know what an exercise you know
what sound I can't make what almost all
of the sounds associated with proper
Spanish pronunciation at least according
to my children because my kids learn
mostly in Spanish they speak mostly
Spanish at school and when I try to
speak to them in Spanish or say anything
in Spanish they always say okay I was
like gay like I'm mad but they literally
don't know what I'm saying like that is
like daddy no that's wrong like Alice in
her ice water yeah Allison just be like
no no daddy in Spanish she's sure I say
in espanol you say no and then I'll be
like no no daddy espanol we say no
that's very alright this next question
comes from Warren who writes your job Oh
weird to have no power over the podcast
well you know what Hank I was gone for a
long time now once our Holiday
Spectacular is over you can you can go
back to answering half of the cut
questions and also doing the intro I
just started until Elon Musk doesn't get
to Mars in 2027 I just started seeing
this person and he is literally perfect
for me literally perfect is that's a lot
of different quality Lorne let's say if
you just started seeing each other look
okay he's smart he's funny he's cute we
like him he's great I like him too
let's not put too much pressure on the
situation yeah there's a huge catch I'm
moving in four months
to join the Navy SEALs that doesn't
sound perfect that sounds like he's
moving in four months to during the Navy
SEALs I'm moving in seven months to
start law school well those three months
when he's in the Navy
you're not in law school you guys will
have a great time together it's gonna be
tired all the time though before we met
we had both intentionally stayed single
to focus on our careers however we both
know that we have something special
trademark please forgive this because
they know how ridiculous and cheesy I
sound we want to give things time to
breathe and grow but I could already
feel this ominous ticking clock my focus
is completed on law school but I've
always believed that we should love
whenever and wherever and however we can
any advice however dubious would be
greatly appreciated not trying to have
been a hallmark Christmas movie Lauren
Lauren just date long distance yeah I
mean you're allowed to live in a
Hallmark Christmas movie yeah sounds
very home-like Christmassy I mean you're
gonna finish law school at right about
the same time that he's going to be
entering his third year in the Navy
SEALs and then you get married or not
whatever stop putting so much pressure
on the situation Lauren it's okay I mean
it is hard it's hard when you've got a
thing you like this is good this is
gonna be good but then there's this
thing that isn't either of you it's just
the universe conspiring against this
loveliness right like circumstances are
organizing themselves not right in your
favor and that is important to realize
that milk Jonna vera told you about the
time with the milk when I was in Middle
School No so I was this a very
applicable story okay I was a middle
school student and some young people
stole my milk yeah my chocolate milk my
unopened 25 cent chocolate milk I
remember and they were passing it around
on the table keep away from from nerdy
Hank boy and they then swapped it for a
chocolate milk that had been drunk but
they had closed the little carton so
that it will take it hadn't they gave it
to me and and I was like I think and
then I got mad extra mad because I
thought that they were giving it and
being nice but it turned out the
meanness was continuing and then I threw
it back at them and then they threw it
out into the middle of the cafeteria
where I proceeded to go over and stomp
on it and realize that it was the
original not empty milk
how is this story applicable it's
applicable because they didn't intend
for me to stomp on the milk that was
like that was farther than they wanted
to take it who's who who are the like
mean milk stealing jocks of this store
of the story of the Navy SEALs in the
wall school students the the Navy SEALs
in law school oh you mean like the
institution's yeah are the bad guys just
the situation okay and it's just like
that it was it was set up like it's not
a it's not perfectly it's not a perfect
analogy I would actually go further than
that I would say that it's also not a
good analogy it may have nothing to do
it with the situation here's I mean so I
think we've solved it for you as the
good news Lauren you need to purchase 25
cents worth of chocolate milk stomp on
it and wait for the positive results the
school teachers and administrators then
had to talk to me as if I was the one
who had caused the ruckus because I had
stomped on a 25 cent chocolate milk and
made a mess yeah and then I had to
explain the situation but it nobody was
truly at fault yeah I mean obviously no
like they didn't they didn't want the
milk to get stopped yeah so no one was
at fault it was just a situation though
it did begin with bullying so they
shouldn't have done that
yes this is not it's not working this
next question comes from Mary Kate who
writes Dear John and Hank that would be
the worst answer I've ever heard to a
question you asked I didn't ask it a
question I asked just love love and
follow your heart but don't drop out of
Law School
this next one comes from Mary Kate who
writes Dear John and Hank I'm over the
moon excited to get married and
why but I'm in a bit of a pickle mmm oh
I just read on it's not a literal pickle
unfortunately would have been amazed
question I'm in a bit of a pickle how do
I get out of this pickle to get married
that's it birds jeyonce reports that he
does not want to marry pickle I recently
accidentally came across some Intel that
my mom had been planning a surprise for
me at my wedding I'm a huge fan of
surprises
okay this one is a bit much she intended
to have a live owl fly our rings to us
at the ceremony I understand the impulse
but you're just like if you don't know
this is gonna happen you're gonna be
like Oh God
giant bird attack who doesn't think who
thinks oh what a nice surprise no you
think we're being attacked by a bird you
don't think every year to somebody does
die from an owl attack while I'm reading
the rest of the question I know she has
this idea out of thoughtfulness and love
I'm a big potter fan that doesn't you
know what like I read those books and at
no point does an owl carry wedding rings
into a wedding ceremony but anyway this
is clearly a no good terrible idea in so
many ways here's the issue I was told
this information by someone close to me
because my mom wasn't able to make this
happen
really that's a big surprise good
excellent but they also said that my mom
said guess I'll just have to come up
with a different plan I'm not supposed
to know about the owl situation in the
first place but what if my mom tries to
bring a different species of animal to
carry rings if my wedding my question is
this do I tell my mom I don't want any
avian beatings at my wedding or do I
bust her to make a reasonable surprise
quite contrary mary-kate I mean do you
do you know the story about almost
definitely the murder yeah no I was
gonna talk about Chava milk Oh
I thought we
talking about the alle murder but can we
let go the chocolate milk thing because
it was never a good bit and now it's
been going on way too long but you know
what was a great bit the pickle the
plums the pickle uh okay yeah I did look
up the owl murder and I'm a little
confused okay
I'm not entirely a hundred percent sure
that the owl did it oh it is very
controversial because you mean because
the accused human killer yeah probably
killed may have killed it diverse and
previous spouse right right yeah yeah
there's an argument to be made that it
might not have been an owl but there's
also an argument to be made that it was
an owl who knows for sure all we know
for certain Hank is that Mary Kate has
is in quite a pickle um here's the thing
Mary Kate what if you go to your wedding
in a pickle wait but I think so my
feeling is if you know that there's
gonna be a bird that it's okay for there
to be a bird right so you know now well
that if a bird attacks you right it's
just the ring bearer it's part of the
plan but I mean who wants to try to like
wrestle a wedding ring from the talons
of a bird but it's very well trained
bird okay here's guess I'll just have to
come up with a different plan that's the
direct quote from Mary Kate's mom it
doesn't say that it's gonna be a bird it
could be a whale
yeah well goodbye yeah walk in ring bear
ring bearer ring bear a ring bear oh my
god Mary Kate your mom is going to hire
a panda to come to your wedding oh no
it's a koala it's all gonna be okay a
non bear bear walk with me here yeah so
the bear obviously isn't gonna be able
to hold the wedding rings right
yeah I'm what's it gonna do well I think
just strap it to him wrong dead wrong
right like three hours before the
wedding you feed the Koala two wedding
rings and then right and then the koala
walks down the aisle
out they come dig them out of the Koala
poop and it's like that like extra
awesome coffee that's been through the
digestive system of a cat or whatever
cleans isn't your wedding ring yes with
this ring I thee Wed yeah yeah that's it
Hank we solved it mary-kate tell your
mom the hair of koala to pick the
wedding rooms but make sure you know a
good amount about koala digestion
because I think that might be real slow
and so you might have to feed it to him
like a few days eh you might have like a
four day wedding we got a got a weird
wedding traditions in America but we
don't have that particular one yeah you
feed a koala to wedding rings and then
the wedding lasts until the fall
sometimes this is like a 10 minute
wedding and then other days is like a
six-week wedding you know oh man good
this is just to say i retweeted the
plums that were in the ice box tweet
which you have probably already seen
forgive me
nice that's good let's got it it had a
surprise ending
Hank we're gonna answer one more
question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon okay but first I have to let
you know that today's Christmas episode
yes it's brought to you by koala poop
the future of weddings this podcast is
also brought to you by really bad print
songs really bad print songs they don't
exist and of course today's podcast is
brought to you by the gloves that were
in the ice box no longer no longer and
not thorny and this podcast is finally
brought to you by aged gatorade mmm been
sitting on that shelf there for seven
days getting slightly sweeter so that
John can like it the way that he likes
it right so delicious and so cold Hank
yeah John before we get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon I want to just
clear up a couple things I have a couple
of Corrections to give I've been gone
for like a month because of my vertigo
but before I left I said that Facebook
might be listening to everything that we
say
our phones I was kidding but lots people
took that seriously Facebook is not
listening everything we say through our
phones they get plenty of data just from
what we choose to give them and I
apologize if that wasn't clear also one
other thing
Ciara wrote in Hank you may remember in
a previous episode of the podcast there
was a young person who was trying to
figure out how to take their secret pet
snake with them to college right that
parent was like you can't have a snake
they got one anyway hid the snake for
more than a year yeah and then had to go
to college and but didn't want parents
find out about the secret snake update
Ciara writes Dear John and Hank I'm a
freshman in college and one of my
greatest fears has recently been made a
reality and it's all your fault there is
a snake loose in my dorm wait is it is
it all our fault Lee one of the
residents had a secret pet snake in her
dorm room and now it is loose wandering
the halls ready to ruin my life I can't
help but assume that someone in my Torm
is a fan of the pod and is listen to
your ludicrous advice regarding secret
snakes and because of that there is a
snake roaming the halls of my building
this is more of a complaint than a
question
[Laughter]
yeah there's dear Centennial residents
housing and Residential Life staff
recently learned that a resident in
Centennial Hall at an unauthorized pet
snake in their room the pet snake
escaped this residence room we're
currently writing to notify you about
this and assure you that this snake does
not pose a physical threat to anyone in
the public press yes an existential
threat maybe but not a physical threat
the coldest of all comforts right don't
worry the bear that we set loose in your
dorm has been declawed all right it has
been fed two wedding rings all right
this last thing comes from Sarah who
says why are you cutting down
honeysuckle it is super sweet and lovely
if you eat it please it will change your
life at Google how to eat honeysuckle
here's the
thing Sara before my vertigo but after I
got home from the Turtles all the way
down to her I spent several weeks
cutting honeysuckle out of my backyard
while building this path that was partly
a metaphor but also like a thing that
took 90 hours of my life and honeysuckle
is an invasive plant and it is a
disaster to a natural indiana plants and
the reason i was cutting it out is so
that we can have some sweet regular
homemade indiana shrubbery not gross
stupid honey suckle so I don't care how
good the juice from the flowers tastes
it is an invasive weed except it's tree
sized could we like harness it and then
like maybe people would want it so bad
that we'd over farley would just like
over harvest it and all be gone
cuz apparel is pretty good I found
honeysuckle it's tasty no we can't
that's a good idea Hank because humans
are traditionally good at over
harvesting anything that we like but we
literally cannot like honeysuckle enough
to get rid of all of it I could for the
rest of my life cutting honeysuckle
pretty hard
like it seems like a bit of a difficult
thing to like bottle like yeah one bud
and then you suck it out and spit it
into the bottle and then one and it's
gonna take a long time and you can get
me Gatorade is available that's all
right I think this last question comes
from Emma writes dear John and Hank I
was confronted at work yesterday evening
with my first official get well card
signing I waffled and I and I found
myself at a loss for what to write I
waffled between ideas for a solid five
minutes and before setting on a short
unfeeling get well soon I can't help but
feel like a horribly unsympathetic
person for not thinking of anything else
but it is for a co-worker and all so
anything more emotional just seemed
weird what the heck is one supposed to
write in a get-well card it feels like
signing yearbooks when you write
something repetitive and codified that
is totally disconnected for many of your
genuine feelings also I can't help but
feel like telling someone to get well
soon is rather insensitive since it's
not usually up to them whether they get
well soon we're not it's is like it's a
great point
why are you telling like I don't know
I already had that idea it's like oh my
god until I read your card it hadn't
crossed my mind well it's never about
liquor that's weird
yeah I uh I hope you get well soon right
I hope you are feel is I work with a lot
of elderly people so I'm afraid this
will slowly pick up a more pressing
issue
please help with my deal Emma with mom
bill because she's in a pickle
but also she's the nun pickle but you
just got it all right Emma
um what you writing this is a great
question thought it was I recently got a
get-well card from all the people at our
office because of the incapacitating
vertigo that I had and I don't want to
criticize anybody because we've worked
with very many nice people but some of
them said get well soon to which my
reaction was I already thought of that
I've already tried that strategy it did
not work and Here I am still not well um
less soon than I would want and the one
that I the one that I like the most the
one that I found the most helpful
personally was I hope you feel better
mmm I hope you feel better is good
because like never not true
even when you're good I hope you feel
better yeah right ice I hope you feel
better do you feel right now dad oh you
seem like you feel pretty good I do but
I could feel better right and I hope I
hope I do soon I hope I I hope I feel
better soon yeah I hope you feel better
soon
it is a universal lift up mm-hmm
and you're never yeah you're never
feeling all the way yeah sometimes I
think people don't need to feel better
than they're currently feeling another
strategy and like that you mean if you
need to feel a little worse than you're
feeling maybe autistic age not almost
never but occasionally another thing
that Emma could do since she knows that
she works with a lot of elderly people
is she could write I understand that you
are an elderly person and this will
probably become more and more of an
issue as time goes on
I don't know if that would be incense
and I hope that you feel better soon but
likely this will continue to be a
problem i if it's not if it's not too
bad of an illness yeah I would draw fish
sure and then I draw a little little
line comes out of the fish's button and
then it says pooped mm-hmm that's the
thing that's it
man I haven't I haven't heard a story
that good since the milk soy milk
story's great it's a good story what is
the news from ours maybe was a little
misplaced
what is the news from Mars NASA yeah
you've heard of them they're great they
are working on the next generation
Curiosity rover thing Mars 2020 Rover
yeah and you may have heard that
curiosity's wheels are not great shape
oh yeah it's a big problem yeah so
they've actually had to start driving
curiosity backward right to just try to
get like the tread worn on the other
side basically yeah
well yeah likely no like the first first
wheels hit the rocks first you know yeah
I get it and so NASA is working on new
wheel designs and they have just let
people know about this cool flexible
chain maille wheel ooh
that's made out of chains yeah that's
gonna give us that the traction we need
but also the flexibility and the
durability that you want in a wheel
that's gonna be driving around on the
surface of Mars for you know hopefully
five maybe even ten years with the
mission like this this wheel I believe
it uses okay so yeah nickel titanium
shape-memory alloy such alloys remember
their original shape and spring back
immediately after deforming meaning they
retain their original shape and
performance so it's a cool a cool new
wheel design coming out of NASA to make
curiosity's new cousins
more durable and long-lasting that's
exciting
but not as maybe not as exciting this
the AFC level did duh Hank
so AFC Wimbledon played I think III
can't remember who I think Charlton in
the second round of the FA Cup the FA
Cup is this competition in England where
for the first two rounds teams from the
lower leagues play each other and then
if they can make it to the third round
of the FA Cup that's when the Premier
League teams and the teams from the
second tier in England the championship
come in okay so like a few years you
might remember that a few years ago you
might remember that AFC Wimbledon made
it to the third round of the FA Cup and
they played Liverpool remember and I guy
was very very difficult for me as I grew
up a Liverpool fan and I go but they're
not gonna beat Liverpool so I'm indeed
they didn't they lost 2-1 but on this
board played Liverpool at home which is
great because it's like a big club and
they come in and it's on TV and
everything but it wouldn't have been
it's not as good as if we played
Liverpool at Liverpool and do you know
why that is because the Liverpool sells
more tickets 60,000 tickets as opposed
to AFC Wimbledon stadium which sells out
at 4800 hmm what if I told you that the
third round of the FA Cup
Wimbledon made it to the third round of
the FA Cup thanks to a goal scored by
the Montserrat II and Messi while Taylor
the resurgent Lyle table without saying
yeah um he's on fire got rid of those
frosted tips she still has the frosted
tennis so nobody's perfect um so they
made it to the third out of the FA Cup
they could have drawn any team they
could have drawn Swindon they could have
drawn the franchise currently applying
its trade Milton Keynes but they drew
the best possible draw Tottenham away
which means that they are going to play
at Wembley the National Stadium because
Tottenham is currently building a
stadium so they're playing this season
at Wembley the place where they won the
League Two play-off to go to Ligue 1 dad
was there my friend Stuart was there you
were unable to attend
rosianna was there it was magical you
would have had a great
I don't know what you're doing parenting
or something so they're gonna play at
Wembley in the third round of the FA Cup
against Tottenham and here's the great
thing Hank two things first off AFC
Wimbledon has never lost a game at
Wembley ever ever they've played two and
they won them both so first off we're
probably gonna win secondly even if we
don't win it is so much money it's so
much money one game against Tottenham is
so much money like we might stay up
entirely because we happen to draw
Tottenham away they're gonna spend this
money immediately I would hope so I
think they're gonna be like be like hey
hotshot twenty-two-year-old more likely
like hey last guy on Tottenham's [ __ ]
do you want to spend the last three
months of the season on loan in south
london and he'll be like yeah of course
I do
great come on Han we can afford your
wages for three months um so it's very
it's incredibly some times in football
results matter and sometimes in football
you just have to pull Tottenham away in
the third round of the FA Cup and like
if we win or tie that would be amazing
but it also doesn't matter yeah if we
lose also amazing I did you him
everybody didn't everybody good at the
game get it get a ticket
is it gonna sell out I don't probably
not call them fans get tickets to the
hotpot third round of the FA Cup it's
probably the only time you play an see
Wimbledon ever don't miss this
opportunity Tottenham it's incredibly
exciting you said ever at the same time
when we giggled the same and I'm
uncomfortable well the last thing I want
to say just before we close the podcast
down Hank is that you know my favourite
character from the DC Universe yeah Paul
Manafort really good joke yeah
the
people say like all the decent universe
isn't that good like what a Paul
Manafort is an amazing story
thank you can't write this crap Paul man
for just had his bail revoked what does
that mean he was on he was out on bail
because he's been charged with
conspiracy against the United States
yeah he was out on bail what'd he do
he says bail revoked because he's been
working with a Russian spy while under
house arrest but on an op-ed piece about
why we should have better relationships
with the Russians what yes so they
revoked his mail I mean this DC Universe
stuff is so amazing Hank what's
happening in DC Universe right now the
Justice League stuff is great the the
you got the Mueller on the one side you
got the crazy man in Florida the others
left with his three passports and his
password to his email being Bond
0:07 it's gold gold gold gold I just
want to congratulate the writers of the
weird timeline in which we found
ourselves this is great this is great
stuff and by I'm recording this in the
past by the way so if in the interim the
president has resigned and/or fired the
Special Counsel and or whatever it's
gold it's all gold it's terrible it's
awful we should I hate myself for paying
attention to it but it's also gold Hank
thank you for popping with me yes John
yes what did we learn to back very
little we learned that the milk story
isn't very good
we heard that it certainly wasn't placed
in the proper place we learned that the
plums that were in the icebox were both
delicious and cold and we learned that
AFC Wimbledon has never lost a game at
Wembley or at least I learned that not
yet when's that game happen January 6th
or 7th or 5th I can't go because my
friend Enrico is turning 40 and I called
my wife and I said do I have to go to
Enriquez birthday party and she said yes
and then I called Enrico and I was like
do you want to go to London and he said
he said I can't because my wife will get
mad because I'm turning 40 so I can't go
to the game I'm kind of annoyed about it
I'm still think
I'm thinking maybe what if I flew his
wife over there do good all right John
thanks for prodding with me this podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson our head of community
and communications it's Victoria bon
giorno this music that you're hearing
and at the beginning is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]